Regina is with us in Phoenix hi Regina
how are you I'm good how you better than
I deserve what's up and I'm all freaked
out now I don't know where to go or what
to do I have been on disability for five
years I felt the cancer and I have no
skill set so I went in and load myself
in school and now I have a loan and and
I don't know what to do with it at this
point because I don't want to keep and
once I get out of school and I leave to
go to work that should clean fight about
the same time I want to do everything I
can do to make someone go away but I
have no clue how to do that I'm divorced
it's just old are you 56 what are you
studying in school how does the medical
coder any biller
okay and when will you graduate from
that 21st okay and so when you get out
of that and you have to start paying the
loan back you get the job right yeah and
you start doing medical coding and you
you get a job doing then I hope you can
get one doing that and then you get
about the business of paying the loan
out I wouldn't have done it the way
you're doing it but I don't see any
reason to freak out just go follow your
plan through play through okay I mean
just finish now you got you borrowed
enough to do the school and it's already
paid to the school right no exact amount
you're done no more borrowing no
more borrowing and you work your extra
jobs or whatever you got to work to eat
while you're finishing up the school and
then you graduate from that you increase
your income hopefully that was the idea
and then you go back and you knock the
loan out how much did you borrow ten
grand okay all right
and what do you make now I'm disability
so I make about nine hundred a month
okay and you live all you live on that
yeah basically I got you basically I
don't work right now I know so I mean
that's that's all you got to live with
right so you're eating on that yeah all
right and you've done something to keep
your lifestyle way down and then when
you get out of this and you start
medical billing what do you think you'll
be making there all right so your
incomes going to triple - quadruple by
this time next year which means if you
kept living kind of like you're living
now you could pay that loan off in about
20 minutes couldn't you yeah you're
gonna be okay
just just finish though play through
finish the degree get the job and knock
below now I don't need I don't think you
need to freak out it's not exactly what
I would have signed you up for but
you're there now you can do this you can
do this I think you're just scared
because you've been through a lot but
you're stronger than you think you are
you're a cancer survivor get after it
kiddo you can do this
[Music]